narcos Mexico your kids I mean this is
this is a very intense subject and
you've mentioned that your kids know
about your work do your kids know what
this is all about no of course yeah no
no I had to sneak out of home every day
they would ask him what are you doing
and I just another Netflix thing you
know and they're like yeah like
trollhunters and three below again
that's amazing it yeah yeah kinda I mean
in two years they're gonna be like well
yes that's right that's right they're
not be the appropriate age exactly but
it's not no no they they know very
little about what I'm doing and it is it
is difficult to to come back home and
pretend you had a great day and work and
you come from playing this man right
yeah this is very intense role and what
I and depicting this well this this this
drug world and one of the things that's
amazing is that everything is shot in
different parts of Mexico mm-hmm and and
I think what's really incredible about
that is that you're not there's so many
times I think in our culture when we
shoot for Mexico and they picked just
one location join Amin and yeah part of
Los Angeles and it's that location
you're showing all different kinds of
aspects of Echo yeah patients that
you're shooting in yeah that's that's a
that's the thing I really like about
this show that they they're really
shooting where things happened and even
though the story is it's it's a terrible
story a story that needs to be told to
understand our present but at the same
time the show shows the diversity of my
country you know you have the Pacific
Coast the Caribbean the goal of the
north which is that sir the jungles like
you see all of that you see also a lot
of what the talent has to offer in
Mexico you know all these roles mean a
lot to these actors that are certainly
they're seen around the world right you
know and and and you see what we're
capable of
I'm really happy it's been two amazing
years but I'm also really happy not to
be going to set because you
day two it is a hard day but you have to
be there in the morning no that's not
the problem
no no I mean I wake up early like I do
wake up to see my kids in the morning oh
not me no I gave that up I have my
manager take care of that expected he
tells me they're doing just fine but
what is it what is it about going to
send no no it's it's just that the the
material you know and and and the
violence and what it means also because
this the story is getting really close
to to the present you know these these
second season ends in the beginning of
the 90s end of the eighties yeah so it
is the Mexico I lived in you know all
those names I know those guys they're
they're still out there you know many in
very powerful positions and and the
story is getting close is getting close
is getting close and we haven't realized
how much we have to do to fix this issue
you know right we have a clip here in
Arcos Mexico and I believe this is where
you're meeting with someone who this
other person is it'll be like the the
state the how they say the Secretary of
State
yeah like kind of depressing you're
meeting someone who's very very high up
in the government who thinks they're
gonna be in control in this meeting and
I think it's don't quite go that way
let's take a look what to me to me
owners and owners let's we first annual
permits it myles grint expert honest
buys me organizes uni sook insane meet
me on a the all knowledge you saw was a
ferry Electro's well
is the basic a Brussels India
broke Akira's our president there's a
pies
you may listen now assume if area
a regular meal bell rings
see me to toss a laverna
that's great I will not be screwing with
you